every week on our show during the
election process we'd like to talk to a
different segment of the American
populace to get their take on this
year's election here to represent the
small but formable voting bloc of former
presidents of the United States of
America is former President of the
United States of America george w bush
[Applause]
thank you thank you for coming mr.
president very nice to have you here
hello Chris hello my fellow Americans
hello people of online especially
especially at weed Boehner 69 he's a
funny guy Chris you should have him on
all right well we'll definitely consider
that but I have to say it is a real
honor to have you on this program that's
legitimizes what we do here thank you
for coming well thank you thank you
first of all Chris I just like to say
something about my cousin Billy Bush
he's been in the news a lot lately
him and that disgraced pumpkin Donald
Trump talking on that bus and I just I
just want to say one thing we bushes
don't act like that okay we we have
standards and we were raised a certain
way and we would never under any
circumstances ride a bus
you know here when you're a bus you ride
in the limousine or jump-jet or maybe a
monster truck called Sasquatch Express
you know never a bus it boggles the mind
yeah well listen there's a very
important distinction and I've you know
it's too bad we didn't find out about
that earlier but a lot of Republicans
have come out against Donald Trump's so
people are confused about where you
stand where do you stand
well I'll tell you what Kris uh this
this dunderhead is making me look great
yeah I mean did you see where I where I
hugged Michelle Obama a few weeks ago
see that why yeah I see where she's
almost kind of making a snarky face and
trying to hug you but you're not really
giving back now I'm kind of
affectionately leaning in dude yeah I
guess maybe wanna bet you giving her a
little lean but she's sort of I think we
both feeling like this is nice I don't
know if I mean the look on your face is
sort of like can you believe this over
here I mean it's like a little seem you
know what though I don't wanna take it
away I guess it is a sweet moment it's a
sweet moment well well it was and I
don't know why you're trying to debunk
it no absolutely
hi pop sorry I apologize and let's face
it the internet ate it up like a like a
two-for-one deal the Cheesecake Factory
which by the way is a good restaurant
with terrific snacks and appetizers
and I recommend their cheesecake Chris
oh good recommendation I mean everywhere
you go cheesecake yeah why do I dig
around don't you get like just go right
to us go right yeah yeah I mean no
you're right you're absolutely right
it's not a chicken factory or safe
factory you're the only one who gets it
yeah I'm upset now I mean I that picture
was so cute even I almost forgot about
how I invaded Iraq over WMDs that
weren't there I just stabilized an
entire region Chris but but no one seems
to care anymore
yeah thanks to the the bozo Trump here
yeah folks have forgotten about how I
tanked the economy or how I I didn't get
bin Laden heck you know Kanye West even
said I hated hurricanes but all
forgotten all gone yeah it's all good
so ok so this is an interesting thesis
Amy you're saying Trump is improving
your image so does that does that mean
that you're supporting him he's a he's a
dangerous man Chris and back in Texas
where I'm from born and raised you don't
talk about women the way he does we got
a we got a funny kind of justice down
there some might even say it's illegal
but uh but if he ever tried jamming his
tic-tac covered cow-dung down a lady's
throat in Texas we give him what we call
the amaryllis steak and eggs that's
where that's where you cook them up a
nice t-bone steak medium-rare with
scrambled eggs and a Saeta grits and
then you drag them with your truck okay
and now he's saying the election grid
the only thing that's rigged is is that
stuff Chupacabra on top of his head
I don't know how he keeps it on there
but I sure hope Hillary knocks it off oh
okay that's that's really interesting so
that so that means you're endorsing
Hillary then why well look I'm not the
decider Chris yeah I know but I just you
know I feel like so many bushes have
already indicated their support
including your daughter Barbara Bush
your wife Laura Bush your father and
former President George HW Bush Gavin
Rossdale the lead singer of Bush the dog
in the bush baked beans at almost every
roller coaster operator at Busch Gardens
this bush near the i-80 outside Akron so
what about this last square here what
about George W Bush are you endorsing
Hillary what are you doing look at my
wife's hat
well that was I was asking if your she
looks almost British she yeah yeah
she looks very pretty she but I but I
was asking who your support I'm sorry
Chris I wasn't paying attention okay I'm
Reza mirai's by my she looked like she a
part of the cast of Downton Abbey yeah
she does definitely looks like a cast of
Downton Abbey is it a hat that you would
think maybe a president that you might
want to see in the White House would
wear or I still don't know what you're
driving to okay all right I'll take
world history for 400 all right there
right there okay world history it is in
the 2016 presidential election George W
Bush endorsed this candidate look Chris
if Trump takes this thing Laura and I
have very comfortable underground bunker
we can move to okay it's got a
mini-fridge for snacks and sodas and a
much larger walk-in freezer with
thousands of hungry man dinners we have
every season of just shoot me on DVD so
I'm gonna be down there with Princess
Kate and Nolan Ryan while society gets
overrun by wild dogs and racists my
advice is don't let that happen America
don't let that sack of rotten sweet
potatoes anywhere near the White House
I mean those are very strong words so
that's a yes for Hillary truth be told I
I have a strict no endorsement policy
since I got burned on a deal before I
was governor of Texas oh yeah yeah I
remember that I mean I love I love them
being pants it's hard not to now you
have a lot of them president george w
bush thank you so much for being here do
you have time to stick around and play a
game with us after the break of course
I've got time what do you think I'm
doing here Chris
literally all I have is time I mean
you're gonna be lucky if I even leave
okay well I'm glad you're sticking
around we're happy to have you here
we'll be right back with former
president george w bush and more
@midnight sticker
[Applause]